hey they get too excited of from the
bonding but you needed a bet you need
people need a vet that's nothing like I
have some long lasting friendships and
there is drama
there is ups and downs there is things
that happen but at the end of the day
the loyalty that I have with them is is
very irreplaceable
yeah like we do have a really strong
network of people that we can count on
they're not always gonna be the greatest
they're sometimes annoying but still I
have a support system but that shit's
built over years grow like you got to
build that [ __ ] over time and I don't
even we don't even get deep into
friendship until like years later yeah
but if you're pouring out your emotions
on the first day or two people gonna
think you've nuts yeah they're really
well and that's what my friend okay so
here's the thing Mike one of my cousins
right [ __ ] bless her soul
this this girl is so warm and inviting
you can literally pour out your [ __ ]
soul to her the first day you meet her
and she will accept you she will listen
to you she does not realize that the
world is not her so she's out there
doing that with everyone she can't
[ __ ] make a connection to make
friends and we're all telling her chill
yeah you gotta you gotta you gotta ease
into the friendship yeah she's like now
I want to connect deeply with people and
I'm like I see that you do and I see
that you're willing to give and you're
willing to receive but you have to
understand that other people aren't
ready for that and you scare them when
you talk about [ __ ] marital problems
or whatever on the first day you guys
hang out and you're crying to them for
two hours they think you're nuts and
then it's like it's amazing that she can
receive that for other people and that
that might be her case like she might be
very open and okay and other people like
she would receive them but what if she's
like too forceful with the friendship
who knows but I think that the stages is
like you go do you find common hobbies
you do have common interests you hang
out you play like on a surface level you
crack jokes you have a pleasant
encounter you like this person I like
this person because we can always skate
together or what
right and then you move on oh [ __ ] I
find out that he has a brother in prison
I got a brother in prison we can bond
over that sad [ __ ] right or whatever it
is it could be like hey it seems like we
both had a car accident together
traumatic car accident it could get a
little bit negative but generally you
want to have Pleasant encounters with
people and build it over time and then
there's the whole sacrifice part of it
of like oh I'm down and out I need some
help can you support me yeah whatever
like but if you come straight out the
bat and you're like yo I got these
struggles I need a [ __ ] pour out yeah
that's I mean that's really hard to
write because I also think that you're
you're giving an apple and you're
expecting an Apple back but you keep
getting an orange right and that's just
not how the world works it's like the
same concept with doing good deeds in
this world there's a lot of people who
are great great people like your friend
who's so gracious and they give and they
give and they give but when sometimes
when they don't receive what they give
out they're like well that's [ __ ] up
well that's just not how things work
yeah when you do a good deed you just do
a good deed and you don't expect things
in return and in this case - for you
maybe because I don't really know you
like that you're going on this stuff to
find a really hardcore connection but
are these other people that you meet
willing to do that as well maybe they're
not like joe said maybe there's yourself
they just want to gloat blow some glass
baby you know let's go blow some glass
and they're just having a good time and
then you're expecting something more out
of a friendship that either one hasn't
had the time develop that way or number
two that's not really what they're
looking for yeah deep emotional
connections I think are cultivated over
time a lot of inter done in spurts
yeah they're not done in intense
passionate deep like encounters I think
that's more of a romantic thing that's
it those for [ __ ] sure like even if
we wanted to relate to ourselves to like
you know I think a lot of times people
look at your my friendship yeah and
Bard's and they go like I want that we
I've known these guys for 10 years now
we didn't even start doing business
together until like four or five years
into it yeah it took a while like this
this stuff isn't easy yet meeting people
and having a good time is easy but it
looks like what you're looking for is
somebody to count on
to be you know your point of
accountability to be your best friend
yeah I that that doesn't happen that
quick and also to if you're putting
yourself in a position where you're
coming up and then maybe you're spilling
your heart out to this person you're
probably scaring them away I would be
freaked the [ __ ] out I would if I came
out and I was just here to watch some
clowns you know I mean like juggling
[ __ ] yeah else and you're like well my
dog in my cat died I've been like [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] can I hug you and cry and
you see my elephants all matted [ __ ]
they're all juggling like can I cry with
you right now and then you turn to the
left she's like I'm just trying to enjoy
this [ __ ] lion show right now I don't
know it's weird - it's like well when
can i when can i open up and that's the
part that you're gonna have to feel that
and also to figure out who you should
open up to and should you even at this
point yeah right cuz I wouldn't just
open up to somebody about all my stuff I
mean for me because it's for
entertainment purposes I'm very
comfortable with who I am and I have a
strong group of friends I tell people
all about my [ __ ] but there's still like
this 30 40 % that I keep between me and
Joe yeah I keep between me and Bart me
and Mary oh there's levels to this [ __ ]
hell yeah there's levels to this like we
always say - there's there's the homie
there's the homie and there's the homie
homie yeah hey you know there's a friend
homie homie homie homie it's all at
different stages man let me be the rest
of your stuff - well and I mean also
it's so difficult because I don't really
know her what she's going through it
could be that she's too thirsty or I
could just genuinely be she's into a tea
area maybe - yeah cuz I know that people
in small towns they're limited man like
Bo's like she grew up in a small town
and she was limited to the owl that's
right and I have family members too that
are like a little too intelligent for
the community that they live in and I'm
like but if your genius ass just [ __ ]
move - I don't know Boston or like the
Silicon Valley or if you're and around a
bunch of other people that were
like-minded that might work - you also
check this out dude that you're actually
right cuz what she wrote here she goes
one of my hobbies is aerial arts but
there isn't anyone in my area that I
that shares it the only hobby that's in
my area seems our boardgames DMD Larkin
and geeks beer trivia I live in a
low-income blue-collar area yeah so not
much to do I've tried to get into a
low-income blue colored nerds that like
Dungeons and Dragons and [ __ ] yeah
that's kind of rough yeah that's pretty
much my only hobby where there's a
chance to meet people in real life my
other hobbies are art animation not
anime I grew out of it
storytelling travel storytelling
traveling an illustration I'm not
financially stable too much so your
honor right it's her area this is your
area yeah yeah I mean it's probably a
mixture of both right like yeah
sometimes it's also like this right how
important is a social life to you and
finding this group to be connected with
because if it's that important maybe you
should move and find a place that fits
you better because we that's one of the
things I say too like we live in one of
the greatest [ __ ] countries in the
world where you can be whoever the [ __ ]
you want you can literally be a
completely gay dude in West LA run
around in your underwear with the flag
and just [ __ ] parade with no
restrictions and everybody loves you
like a [ __ ]
during the day he's a [ __ ] lawyer
yeah yeah or that same guy could be in
the Bible Belt small town where he feels
ridiculed and he's just like I got to
get out of this mess you know like you
know it's like but if only he lived in
West LA he would have been himself you
know I would like to say this too for
her because she says that she doesn't
feel financially stable to move I think
that's a lot of people when they when
there's this huge leap that they have to
take right it's hard it's it's hard
because it seemed at a point right now
where you have tried so many different
options to make this situation work and
there is no guarantee that if you move
into a different place that you'll be
able to find a new connection with
different people that have your interest
that's a very very scary and brave thing
to do because there is no you're right
there is no guarantee that if you leave
from this point you go somewhere else
you might find that you're now in a
worse financial situation and you still
haven't been able to find or connect to
anybody else which by the way if you
come to LA a lot of people find that - a
lot of people have that happen to them
because they have this
certain idea of what la is la is and
what they want from it and when they
come here they go oh [ __ ] I'm actually
kind of lonely out here yeah a lot of
people in this city are very very lonely
because they're too busy trying to be
famous
exactly so for you if you want to be out
of your situation and I know that it's I
don't know what your financial situation
is but if I were to put myself and the
reason why I feel like I'm okay saying
this is because I grew up [ __ ] dirt
poor
I grew up dirt as poor my parents were
[ __ ] dirt poor too we went up from
being [ __ ] dirt poor to being a
decent middle-class right like lower
middle class really lower middle class
and in order for me to move to this city
I had to work three jobs I saved up a
[ __ ] ton of stuff and I cut out a lot of
Mike my interpersonal relationships you
made a big leap of faith yeah I had five
hundred bucks in my [ __ ] bank account
when I came to LA so you know there yeah
a lot of things do seem impossible
because it's very daunting but if it's
something that you really need and that
you really want you can do it and there
is a high chance of failure but I think
that when you say you're financially
unstable I do believe you because so is
I but if it's if it's killing you and
you've tried out all your options what
do you have to lose by trying to move
out somewhere else yeah if you already
broke what's the difference now you'd be
broke with dope friends yeah it's like
you're either broken alone